welcome to Android fundamentals getting
started on Android is straightforward
simply installing Android studio and
creating a new project is enough to have
ticked the HelloWorld box on your
Android resume but that's not why we're
here
we're also not here to teach you Java
and we're not going to walk you through
every API in the Android SDK but what we
will do is to help you build a real app
we'll dig into the fundamentals of how
Android works its patterns and best
practices our course is deeply rooted in
code but this isn't a copy-paste code
lab will teach you the principles you
need and help you navigate the hundreds
of resources like sample code
documentation and Stack Overflow that
you'll be using in your career as an
Android developer getting started is
easy but building something great is
harder which is why we're here we'll
work right alongside you and by the end
of this course you'll be able to turn
your app vision into reality and you'll
build it the right way so in that spirit
of collaboration we'll begin by telling
you a little bit about us and where
you'll be seeing us throughout the
course Katherine why don't you get us
started
sure